i don't believe that the kremlin
actually wants to invade all the way
across ukraine uh i don't see a big red
arrow that goes across ukraine um i
don't think that russian federation
forces actually could do that not
against modern-day ukrainian forces and
a very resistant population but i do
think that they
intend to
isolate ukraine from the black sea and
sea of azov the operational objectives
would be to take those coastlines
and really
i mean that would wreck the ukrainian
economy as well as
probably lead to the fall of the zlinski
government
all the pieces are in place
and it could
uh move forward
on pretty short notice i think
the reason for this of course is
the kremlin
has decided to put pressure on the west
and and i think to present ukraine as a
failed state to prevent
ukraine from ever being really able to
integrate into the west in the eu or
nato
i think the main goal of the kremlin is
to
re-establish this sort of sphere that
people would have recognized from the
18th and 19th century where russia gets
to dictate the foreign policy and what
goes on inside nations
on its periphery
no matter what those nations want to do
kremlin has deployed at least thousands
of soldiers and all of this equipment
around the ukraine in order to put
pressure on the zelinski government and
hope to provoke them into doing
something or to ratchet up concern
inside europe in order to gain
concessions to to push back gains
by former soviet republics and former
warsaw pac countries to push that back
the best way to prevent this is for the
west
not just the united states but the west
with the european union and nato allies
to stick together
and to be clear to the kremlin that use
of force to continue changing
internationally recognized sovereign
borders
is not acceptable
now
diplomacy that results in any of
russia's uh what i think are totally
unrealistic demands being met
i think that's that's not diplomacy that
would be appeasement and i also i don't
think this should be happening over the
heads of ukraine or poland or other
countries i mean this is not the 18th
century where two big powers make
decisions about how to divide up
territory i think in the 21st century
nations are ought to be able to choose
their own foreign policy and make their
own decisions
you